hey youtubers is Charlie so in honor at
the flash midseason finale
i thought id be fun to do a video on the
reverse flash, or Reverse FLASHES
you could consider them part
applies family be using when people talk
about the flash family the talking about
the hero characters
we still don't know who the Virgin is
did this show is going with
it could be incorporating some
multiverse theory their differently
mixing and matching things
it's none of the characters that we
think it is right now so we can talk
more about the reason to replace my
episode review tonight
so be sure to subscribe to get that so
now let's talk a little bit about the
man yellow
so the Virgin other rivers flash you met
first depends on when you started
reading comics
or watching the movies and TV shows
there at least five different versions
the character
in another one if you consider the black
flash party that line
I will for the purposes this video but
technically the black lashes
that physical embodiment up dead you
know are that negatives be force
so it's not really part of the fun
lineage so here's everybody from back to
front
from being the new 52 universe there's
the rival
from the Golden Age d'gary days the
original professor zoom
a bard on from the late nineteen sixties
the hunters Oman zoom
from dove John's rebirth Aaron Anderson
from the late nineteen nineties
and then currently in the new 52
universe that Daniel West Salem
the backlash was also create during the
nineteen nineties but subsequent virgins
the character
have been used more as a counterbalance
to the positive flashes and professor
zoom
so technically it's not a villain all
their powers are based on his be forced
technically hunters all mine is a little
bit different but it's all about moving
fast through space and time super fast
seek a look at the mall is like a really
dysfunctional Brotherhood speedsters
a really terrible for attorney the Jazz
he's the shit outta you
the new TV show hasn't really given a
name to this be forced yet
and as in the first episode Barry Allen
has no idea that other flashes existed
before in like
G character or will exist in the future
so let's just start with the first one
the first version observers flash was
called the rival
his real name was doctor Edward clarice
and he was a professor at the University
the Jager
went to he recreated the chemical
accident at gate
garrick his powers in called the formula
the Los 89
he started mass-producing the formula
and wearing a darker version A G
character costume
in committing crimes but the conceit was
is that the formula was very temporary
so eventually he was cut and thrown in
jail
in a subsequent incident clarence brand
so fast that he at the speed of light in
entered the Speed Force
but you keep your energy Geoff Johns use
a ride on the TV show right now
brought that character back whenever he
was writing the Justice Society comic in
the early 2000's
I was forget how Geoff Johns is really
notable for bringing classic characters
back
in fact he's the one that brought Barry
Allen bag during the rebirth comic
do not be surprised if you see a lot a
classic heroes and villains
show up on the flash in a row this
season eventually he turned and appears
be force again in
escaped so he's forming up there
somewhere but technically he's more but
Jake Carrick enemies not really Barry
Allen enemy
next we had the first zoom character a
bard on
known as professors im he was an enemy
of the Barry Allen flash turn the Silver
Age
his character was the start a tying the
river splashes
to the good flashes in a blood relative
way it really took the idea of the flash
family to a literal place a bard was
from the 25th century
so like four hundred years from now in
the way way for future
he was the start this causality time
loop that would become a huge part
%uh all subsequent flash stories she
started out as these
crazy Barry Allen fan who at that time
had been long dead
so we had plastic surgery to make
himself look like barry
then replicated the accident to give
implant powers found the cosmic
treadmill
in trying to go back in meet him in real
life just imagine when his time there
must look like
Yanks so I miscalculated the time travel
ended up arriving a couple years
after Barry Allen a died he traveled to
the flash museum
and learned that he was destined to
become a criminal and as a result under
stress is a time-travel
and learning is true fate he went
completely nuts he tried to pass himself
off as the real Barry Allen
until Wally West beat the crap out a
moment then back to the future
so then like way leader in the comics
they can rebuild the character a little
bit but it's still not a whole lot of
time travel
we we later he started using the name
professors im
it kept trying to go back in time to
change the past so that he could defeat
the flash
this was also the start love when the
reverse flashes started trying to kill
people
in Barry's family so remember that
trailer for the flash TV show
we see aversion to the rivers flash was
there when Berry's mother was being
murdered
mild spoiler warnings but I'm getting a
lot of you already know the plot
flash rebirth that was published like
five years ago so I don't worry too much
about spoilers in the comments
especially for students like super super
old
a board on travel back so many times and
her berry and family in so many
different ways but finally
barry just snapped his neck and then
retired thirteenth century
I know they're planning to bid fast and
loose with time travel in Heroes doing
awful things
during a bard on there we also learned
that his family descended from Barry's
family
a bard was the descendant of cobalt blue
berries secret twin brother
and a confusing it all happened back in
the comics in the nineties
so the doctor who delivered Barry in his
twin brother
also deliver this other woman's baby
named Charlene gone
he accidentally killed her baby so he's
secretly gay for
berries twin brother and he was raised
as a bon the interesting part about all
this
is that on the flash TV show detective
pretty boy
is named Edward on we don't know enough
about him yet but he might secretly be
related to bury due to some
weird time travel paradox stuff going on
TV shows tend to oversimplify really
complicated book light skin head
gameofthrones soldiers have to wait and
see how the TV show deals with their
connection
the flash rebirth character brought the
airport on character back whenever Geoff
Johns brought Barry Allen back
and at the end of all that the severed
don's connection to this be forced in
lock them up in
airheads prison on a TV show that's the
place where barry's father is in prison
so
if they ever do any prison scenes be on
the lookout for cellmark
Don and us begins the hunters on LeMans
zoom era
Somen was a police officer with Wally
West in Keystone City
solomon's area of expertise was
criminology and psychology so he's been
all this time trying to get
inside criminals heads his father was a
serial killer
any and a lot a bad luck that resulted
in his wife leaving him
in getting paralyzed from the waist down
during one of Gorilla Grodd attacks on
the city
Sienna legitimately troubled past he was
always a little bit resentful and is
being stuck behind a desk because he was
actually a pretty good police officer
but he always looked up to 18 West they
were good friends he did know the he was
the flash
whens allman asked why to change is
passed to reverse the accident
any refused the woman tried to use the
cosmic treadmill himself
so course that went horribly wrong
blow up in his face in severed his
connection to the time stream giving him
the ability to move through time and
space
he was able to travel in super speeds
just like the flash but his powers were
not based on the Speed Force and said he
was moving through times so when every
talk to speech would change speeds
causing the talking it's really funky
way
as a result wallet to you also went
pretty insane
and concluded that point was perfused to
help him because he didn't know real
tragedy
says all men went back in time to try
and kill while his pregnant wife
and even though cause the miscarriage
while he was still able to stop him by
borrowing speed from the other flashes
so this brings up a really good point
the idea that flashes can grant their
powers for their speed
other flash is making them faster we
only know about Barry Allen on the flash
TV show right now
but it's possible if another flashers up
they can make very faster
so the next version to the river
splashed exist was inertia
he was a clone a BART Alan he was
actually cute party Infinite Crisis
inroads revenge story line before the
new 52 reboot
so he is most notable for stealing zooms
powers
and then getting the ropes to help him
kill Bart Alan
since evil ends up turning on itself
eventually keep of course went mad
then killed hunters allman then himself
was killed by the roads who were taking
revenge
for be tricked in the killing part Alan
so this is where we get the new 52
universe
and current day right now the reverse
flash is actually
Daniel West the brother iris West he
just calls himself zoom
he got his powers from a freak accident
the granted this be forced to a buncha
people
during an attack from the Rogues that's
also the same event the gave the roads
there rely powers
on the TV show we've only met iris
Weston detective west so we don't know
for their gonna be doing the Daniel
character
it seems like that is gonna stick with
the modified flash rebirth storyline for
inspiration but
expect to see aspects from all the
different versions the characters
and I totally would not be surprised if
they combined
Edward on character depth pretty boy
character with hunters Oman
but as you turn let me know in the
comments below which version at the
river's flash is your favorite
and which version do you think the show
is gonna do so quick reminder
my episode review will post tonight
after the episode airs we can talk about
some
reversed last the reason that I'm eating
plenty but it's been years in the
offseason to
but a rope to climb is also going to be
tomorrow
I'm not trying to burn studio for that
too for racial gold is because
the story is supposedly based on a very
notable
Batman comic Batman 232 I think to be
specific
so if you're on your mobile phone or on
your tablet you can click up here for
extra links it seems the links over here
but click here for that review all
posted tonight listening ears
everson and review and click here to get
ready for a ride tomorrow
thank you so much watching floods all
hype I and shifting
into reverse up